if we're looking at mouth shots there I
actually find a lot of success from male
shots but that's only been within the
last one two years because that's been a
lot more focused as well so my advice to
people would be in the success that I've
seen is localized male shots so if I've
got a candidate in Manchester I'm
contacting manchester-based companies
saying I've got this candidate I've got
a candidate with wound care experience
I'm contacting all my wound care clients
and the way that I know where my clients
are are hot lists call lists whatever
you might call them in your agency it's
just all about segmenting it to make
your life as easy as possible